I'm waking up in a hotel room with my husband.
We just had room service. My hair looks like this for a reason.
And this is our Christmas gift to each other.
Usually every year we. We don't really do like physical gifts.
We do a staycation and we'll go shopping
or we'll have lunch
and we'll just have a nice relaxed pace kind of time.
Um, my husband and I have been absolutely drowning recently.
Um, to the point where we're just.
We're both just completely tapped out, right?
And we need to recharge our batteries.
So we are gonna go recharge our batteries today.
I'm gonna go get this under control
and we're gonna have a lovely day.
And I love doing things with him.
We giggle so much. We have the best fucking time.
Um, so we're gonna go have a really fun,
wonderful day here in the great city of Charleston.
Um, it is, however,
packed here,
so we also might just hide in our hotel room and make the best of it.
Um, alright,
love you. Bye.